how can people begin to attract the life
that they want to bring abundance into
your life you have to be cultivating an
abundant mindset and so a really easy
way to start is to list the things that
you're grateful for that you already
have and as part of attracting things
into your life or manifestation you know
imagine it being true imagine what it
would look like feel like smell like and
then when you have that Vision in your
mind give gratitude for it becoming true
so then it sets you on a path of I'm
grateful for the that I've got these are
the things that I want and you're
staying positive and abundant and
grateful and that's much more likely to
attract those good things into your life
hey it's EV car Michael and I make these
videos because I need them because being
around successful entrepreneurs who are
pushing who are driving who are doing
amazing things gives me that extra
little motivational inspirational boost
in the morning every day to help me go
off and accomplish great things too and
I hope that this video gives you that
inspiration as well so today let's learn
some practical steps you could take
right now to to bring success into your
life
enjoy step number two is practice
gratitude with ls house so how can we
put the Law of Attraction into practice
now let's go back to our examples and
apply a new way of thinking if you are
caught in thinking negatively about the
world and about yourself this is so
important what would change inside of
you if you looked around and you wrote
down five things that you're grateful
for about the world now this for me is
part of the secret to the Law of
Attraction it's the foundation is
gratitude it's your way of being must be
grateful in order to attract new things
there's so many things in my life that I
should not have attracted because I
didn't have the skills because I didn't
have the tools because I didn't have the
education because I didn't have the
money because I didn't have the
resources so many things that I
shouldn't have attracted but because I
had the foundation of gratitude
passion Joy curiosity those things
started to come to me and they can come
to you as well if you come from that
place of gratitude as your foundation so
you want to think about what are these
things that are important to me in my
life you know it can be simple things it
could be like this cup of coffee that I
have right now it can be that I have a
roof over my head that I've got quality
friends that I'm healthy you know that
I'm walking in nature today it doesn't
have to be some grandiose thing that's
happened to you to be grateful for I'm
so grateful for these little present
moments with people that I care about to
spend an hour on the beach to go for a
walk with a friend to have a good
conversation with someone and talk about
something that I'm going through for me
that's just as meaningful the moments in
between the big moments are just as
meaningful so write down these things or
think about these things this is
something I embed in my daily life when
I wake up I think about what I'm
grateful for when I go to sleep I I
think about reflect on the things I'm
grateful for from that day and it's just
my way of being for as much as I can now
I'm not perfect I make mistakes and
there's times I'm negative but it's
something that I try to really focus on
as much as possible so instead of saying
that you're not enough that you don't
deserve success what if you looked in
the mirror on a daily basis I dare you
to look in the mirror on a daily basis
and say I am enough and I do deserve the
results that I want to create in my life
because I show up because I'm consistent
because I work hard because I care about
my work if you looked in the mirror and
you did this consistently for 30 days
and you actually use the word action in
attraction and you put it into practice
on a daily basis towards that growth I'd
be amazed to see what you attract and
what you manifest in your life step
number three is learn about money with
Jen cero what do you think are the key
things that abundant mindset people
around money do differently than
scarcity mindset of people around money
if you had to say three or five kind of
key things
they appreciate it as you said that that
is a biggie they appreciate it and they
speak about it as they love it they're
not weird about it they're also generous
with it because when you pinch yourself
off from giving you that is sort of a
subconscious way of saying there's not
enough to go around and it's not going
to I'm not in the flow so when you give
generously it's cuz you're scared that
it's not going to come in anymore um
they take risks you know you got to take
risks you are where you are because
you've been doing what you've been doing
so if you want to change your life
you've got to do stuff you've never done
um what else wealthy people they learn
about money like you you focus on money
like that was such a big thing for me
too like when I was broke I I never
wanted to think about money right I was
all about writing songs and you know
doing much you know more noble things
sure sure but then but when you're broke
all you think about is money like I
don't really think about money that much
now that I have it like but every single
decision you make when you're broke is
about I have enough to pay for this can
I afford it what happens if I don't have
right you wake up in the first thing in
the morning and a panic because you got
to pay your bills so you're always
thinking about money so it is really
just sort of getting in the flow with
that and just you know being on good
terms with it and and focusing on it and
and you know how are you going to make
it like being realistic about your
income stre and you know and if you want
to make it you've got to coax it in you
know also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action action
to make sure you're getting results if
you want the worksheet designed
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
Step number four is have a wealth
mindset with Marissa Pier it's certainly
true that in our grandparents generation
if you had an education you were far
more likely to make success to make
money but actually it isn't true anymore
some of the most successful people we
look at and admire and envy did not come
from wealth they didn't have a
university education look at Tony
Robbins an incredibly wealthy successful
idolized coach who came from nothing
look at Opera Winfrey Allan sugar Chris
Evans so many people we look at did not
go to university didn't come from money
and today we have the advantage that if
you can have an idea and monetize it you
can make it having never never gone to
University so the secret to abundance is
not a university education in fact I
know many people who came out of
University and can't get employed it's
not even coming from wealth after all
all petti children came from wealth but
that didn't help them in fact it's true
to say it handicapped them what helps
you to acquire wealth is to have a
wealth mindset how do you have a wealth
mind mindset well think of something you
want to
monetize and you have to really believe
in yourself you see if you think of
James Dyson he looked at a vacuum
cleaner and he made it better than it
was there are people like the woman who
founded Spanx who took shapew wear and
made it better than it already was so
first of all you have to have an idea
what is it in you what could you
monetize create make invent or simply
improve you have an idea that's the
starting but now you must have
phenomenal confidence incredible
self-belief that you are going to make
it and then you have to have a work
ethic you have to put time and effort
into your idea so me for example I
always wanted to be a therapist I wanted
to be the best therapist and then I
wanted to change the word of therapy to
revolutionize it to make it better a bit
like Dyson revolu uiz the hair dryer I
wanted to revolutionize therapy that was
an idea I had an idea I had a belief
that I could do it I came across
roadblocks of course and then I kept
going I did what I didn't want to do I
thought outside the box I put a lot of
work and effort and Innovation into
being something that I knew I could be
and I did it and anyone can take that
formula have an idea apply to that idea
tremendous self-belief phenomenal
self-confidence think outside the box
don't take no for an answer find people
that can help you that's very important
who can help you who can mentor you who
can you role model yourself on and how
much work are you prepared to do do you
think Opera wimpy say I have a show well
I got a show there's a lot of work goes
into having a show Tony Robbins huge
amount of work goes into taking that
show on the road but you can do it an
idea is an idea but when you commit that
idea down into chunks when you get other
people on board when you write it out as
a plan when you put up a vision board
and say I am successful I am doing this
then you can do it and so often you can
just look at a product and think I could
make this better I could reinvent it
that's what happened happens all the
time in publishing because here's
another thing Once Upon a Time you wrote
a book you took it to a publisher they
went h no thank you and you are finished
now you can self-publish and
self-publishing is now very respected so
now you can have an idea to write a book
a man who can take you to Amazon you can
go to create space you can
self-publish you can get people to fund
raise your business there is so many
things that you can do so please please
don't think my education holds me back
that may be a great Advantage please
don't think I haven't got experience
that can be a good thing but let's look
at the blocks that get in your way what
is getting in your way or your thoughts
there is no glass ceiling that is
entirely in your imagination the glass
ceiling is here and you can smash
through that shatter that if you want to
but you have to really believe in your
yourself if you are going to work for
yourself and have your own startup like
Airbnb what a great idea guys that was
sleeping on people's sofas created
Airbnb no University education was
required no experience was required and
yet they built a fantastic business they
had a thought they put into action put a
lot of work into it same thing with Uber
revolutionizing taxi caps it was an idea
and be find that idea was hard work grit
persistence but most of all the idea
that wow I could revolutionize something
as simple as a cab ride so let's have a
look at you what are your beliefs here's
the common ones it's too difficult it's
too hard it takes too much effort nobody
will like it I don't have experience I
didn't go to college I haven't got money
behind me you see if you pick some
amazing people out out they're doing
well they had all of those reasons to
fail but they said it doesn't matter I
don't have money behind me I'll
crowdfund I'll get a loan I'll mortgage
my house I'll do something I don't have
a university education it doesn't matter
that means you think outside the box I
don't have experience you can get
experience so please don't allow beliefs
to hold you back beliefs hold you back
have told you the habit of thinking I'm
not good enough I'm not worthy enough
I'm not experienced I'm not old enough
when I was a therapist people say but
you're too young to be a therapist
you're too young to know all this
stuff I don't know who say but aren't I
too old I'm a retire e surely I'm too
old you see all of these beliefs are
only real if you believe them age is not
a barrier background is not a barrier
even knowledge is not a to Barry many
people say I have no idea what I'm doing
Richard Branson called his first company
virgin cuz he was selling audio
cassettes would record them send them
back and get a refund and he was so
naive he called his company virgin
because he was a virgin in business but
he learned as he went along he didn't
have experience but he had one thing
that we can all have phenomenal
self-belief determination commit
commment raw enthusiasm take all of
those things and add to them belief have
a mantra I can do this I can make it
write out every limiting belief you have
right now take a pen take some paper
write a little I didn't go to college
and then underneath write out hey all
the people I admire in the business
world didn't go to college I haven't got
money behind me that won't stop me I
have got experience right out many
people I admire had no experience yet
here they are doing phenomenal amazing
incredible things making money making
business making success acquiring wealth
training other people if we look at
Jamie Oliver Gordon Ramsey some of the
most amazing chefs who started
restaurants had little experience but
they had a passion for food and
enthusiasm so passion enthusiasm Drive
commitment the ability to work hard if
you combine those with extraordinary
self-belief which you can pour into
yourself wire into yourself and fire
into yourself you can make it step
number five is create from a place of
fullness with eart tole you manifest
from a place of fullness not from a
place of lack the fullness is already
there and that also means means if for
some reason it doesn't manifest because
not everybody's desires manifest uh I
mean I don't know if it's still
happening La for example uh if you go to
any any good restaurant in La it's more
than likely that the waiter waitress
will be act as waiting for for their big
breakthrough and it's just not possible
for so many people to have the big
breakthrough in l
some they do few may do but most
probably won't but they have they
probably have other breaks or but
perhaps are much more important than
what their ego tells them is important
and to add to that I love this what
you're sharing here because I want
people to really feel this and
understand this and embrace it because
when we try to manifest from
lack it's going to be this needy energy
which was your first point that kind of
kills the the dream of the law of
attraction and when we manifest from a
place of fullness like you spoke of like
feeling a feeling of fullness
holess excitement abundance Joy inside
of us and if it doesn't happen if that
dream doesn't come to us in the next
year or five or 10 years then we've
lived a full rich life every
moment till that moment like we've we've
lived a full year of feeling excited and
passionate and good about ourselves and
that energy is magnetic you will draw in
great People Partners
relationships opportunities that maybe
you couldn't have dreamed of because the
energy you you gave into the world like
you talked about and I think that's the
the big point for me is the dream and
the idea you have maybe your ego once
maybe it you won't have it but man
you'll live a great beautiful rich life
in the process of pursuing it very good
point so in other words the journey is
what matters the PO the arri the
arriving at some destination is the end
point but it's secondary the journey
it's always the journey it's always now
that's what matters and so sometimes
what you want it to manifest uh doesn't
happen but something else manifests that
could be even better in like in many
it's much better than what you know that
Vis absolutely yeah always I always
wanted to be a professional athlete and
I played professional football for about
a year and a half before I got injured
in the injury I broke my wrist and I was
wearing a cast and I had a surgery and I
had a cast on for six months and it took
about a year and a half for me to use my
my wrist again from the injury and
during that time I was in a state of
extreme sadness and a loss and a grief
of this identity that I once had and
this dream that I once had that I was
working so hard for my whole life to
manifest to create and then all a sudden
this injury broke the the my abilities
to do that and I remember thinking what
am I going to do with my life like
what's the point 23 24 years old I'm
like what am I supposed to do now and it
led me into this journey that I'm on now
of doing this interview series and
podcast for the last 10 years that I
much rather have this life than the life
of a professional athlete now like and
sometimes like you said going back to
the beginning of this if we can accept
and surrender in the positive way to see
what good can come it may be challenging
in the moment but it's been a
blessing since then yes that's a lovely
story that's uh that's how it actually
works and another uh thing to mention is
let's say you
do a do let's say you do manifest what
it is you want it to manifest um uh when
you come from this place of
fullness you do not have yes you have an
appreciation of what you have achieved
but you don't have an excessive
attachment to what you have achieved so
let's say you you're able to manifest
that you have a a a house overlooking
the ocean and you manifest it and there
you have it and one day uh you get you
when you get home you find your house is
fallen into the ocean it's
gone right right so the the old thing
that you work so hard for to achieve is
suddenly gone but this place of fullness
that that enabled you to to manifest
that is still there it's
beyond outer
forms yeah and you feel full in life
maybe there's a moment of sadness during
that but if you're not attached to the
physical things you've
manifested um um I'm sure if I lost my
home I feel like it's a sanctuary it's a
it's a it's a beautiful peaceful space
but I've lived in two-bedroom apartments
for most of my life and I felt like
those were peaceful places for me and
it's not like I'm sure I'd be sad for a
minute but then I could also create the
sense of fullness in the next space
exactly and step number six the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
study the law of life with Bob Proctor
have you ever spent any time wondering
how does everything happen how does
everything happen why does the night
follow the day why doesn't the day
follow the day in fact in some places it
does
but I spent a lot of time thinking about
this fact at times it almost drives me
crazy but like right outside of my
studio here is a Japanese maple tree and
there's times of the year it's absolute
Ely beautiful in the spring of the year
it has buds on it then the buds and
leaves pop out and the leaves generally
in the spring are a very deep greeny
Brown they're not a pretty looking Leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color and by Fall the leaves are crimson
red they're most beautiful it is the
most beautiful tree and it's right
outside of my studio I'm sitting here in
my desk and the camera is around me but
out there is that
tree and you know every fall the leaves
turn
red Every Spring they're greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring they're always red in
the fall and greeny brown in the
spring think about it did you ever
wonder why the tide goes way out the
tide comes way back in I spent some time
in the Navy in kennada and I was down on
the East Coast for a while and I was
near the Bay of fundi do you know the
Bay of fundi has one of the highest and
lowest tides in the
world it's absolutely amazing it goes
way out and then comes way back in same
up around Prince George on the west
coast you go onto a ship and you might
be walking up a plank just right
straight up and you go off the ship
sometimes you're going right down that
ship goes way up in the air and it comes
way down very high very low tide now
some places the Tide's not very big they
do have a tide but not too high not too
low why is it so different one place to
another you know why does the leaves
change color why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know just stayed at a
certain length you wouldn't have to cut
it but it would always look pretty you
know do you think about this do you know
that everything in this universe happens
in an exact
way an exact way not by chance but in an
exact way when John Kennedy the
president of the United States actor
asked Dr Warner Von Brun who was the
master of M behind the Space Program
when he asked him what would it take to
build a rocket that would carry a person
to the moon and bring him back safely to
Earth Von Bron answered him in five
words the will to do it that's it the
will to do it he knew he didn't have to
know how to do it he knew he had to
learn how to do it but he didn't have to
know to make up your mind you were going
to do it now why did he say that because
he understands the
laws Von brown one time said after years
of studying the spectacular Mysteries of
the cosmos he would was led into a firm
belief in the existence of God and he
said the natural laws of this universe
are so precise that we don't even have
any difficulty building spaceship we can
send people to the moon and we can time
the landing with a Precision of a
fraction of a
second now he said these laws must have
been set by someone I see the laws as
God's modus opendi but I'm going to tell
you something everything happens by law
when you and I get in harmony with the
law now we do that odds are pretty good
we should understand them but when we
get in harmony with the law then I'm
going to tell you it's just smooth
sailing
success
happens probably be a good to understand
good idea to understand the laws
wouldn't
it think about
it your life is governed by laws that
are not man-made so they're not going to
be man- changed and if you study them
and work in harmony with them I'm going
you'll shock yourself with the good you
can do now I've been doing that for the
last 58 years I'm starting to get a
really a reasonable grip on them but I
don't understand them as well as I want
to or would like
to but I'm going to study a little more
today you know I get my trusty book out
here I have to talk to you about this
book that'll be another
talk study the laws find out what they
right what they're like what are the
laws and then study
them you'll
win certain actions take place you do
things you
know they're
not the optimal things to do but you
can't help it it's
something acts through you um there
there seems to be some power there that
makes you do things that you know no are
not right or not good for you and yet
you can't stop it that seems to be the
case
um and that of course
um is often the case with people who are
with you it might be many different
different areas of your life but uh
um this is also the case with addictions
for example people are addicted to a
certain substance or who are addicted to
eating too much or drinking um there's
something that overpowers them in you
that seems to
obscure the awareness or the awareness
is pushed to to the side and this thing
this this powerful thing does it
anyway and again my answer is a little
bit similar to
um what I said to the first questioner
uh
tonight
the the power of
presence needs to grow in you so
that it is strong enough not to it's not
willpower because willpower is not the
best way of dealing with these things
but
it's what I'm talking about could
sometimes be confused with willpower but
willpower includes the um application of
a force to hold something down let's say
um if your addiction is to um have a to
indulge in intoxicating beverages in
other words booze is the British word uh
then uh and you can feel it it's it
comes on there it comes you know the
bottles are there there they are and you
feel you have to go there and you have
to reach out and you have to pour
yourself a drink now when you're not
aware at all you don't even know what
you're doing you're so unconscious that
you you're already holding the drink and
you're drinking then you at that point
you you even know that you're drinking
uh the same with food I've spoken to
people who have had addictions to food
they often say they wake up when they
already they've already eaten in the
middle of the night they've already
unconsciously gone to the fridge taking
out the chocolate cake and then they're
already halfway through the chocolate
cake when sudden like what am I
doing but so awareness comes in at a
very late Point willpower would be to
hold an urge down let's say I go they
have the pull or even what the example
you gave you want to turn on on the TV
and you know it's not right because I
I'm not here for that and he actually
told us not to do
it and I but I can't help it I have to
go I can't I can't now willpower you
would you would say I'm going to hold
this down I'm not going to do
it and I you can feel the urge but
you're holding it down
um when you hold things
down often after a while the an
explosion happens it's like a boiling
Kettle can't hold it for that long and
then you have some kind of
rationalization in your mind
why you'll do it anyway the mind will
give you a reason I think there are many
modalities that work for trauma what
I've discovered is is that Insight never
really changes Behavior you can see that
your father was overbearing or was an
alcoholic or you could see all these
different things you know like you come
up with the Insight all these different
things the problem that I see with
people is then they tend to excuse their
change by saying oh I had a rough
childhood that's why I am the way I am
they're excusing their pre present
position so and again trauma is a
difficult thing but for me
the person who's living by the
identity in their life that they were
traumatized as a child or whatever it is
or they've had a trauma in their life
I'm not saying forget the trauma and
create another emotion I'm saying that
the person who's willing to go through
the
emotion and keep working on lowering the
volume to it the the we have had so many
people in this work with brutal pasts
really really difficult pasts do the
work and finally they reach that point
where they just break free from the
emotion they look back and I have
interviewed enough of them it's the same
thing they look back at their entire
past and they don't want to change one
thing in their past cuz it brought them
to this elegant moment where they're
liberated they see their betrayers they
see their abusers they have nothing but
love for them now the side effect of
that and many times they'll say it was
like my heart blew wide open they had to
pass through the valley of the shadow of
Darkness to get there they just thought
I I don't know if I can go any further
and they went one more
time and the body literally was
liberated from the past right cuz the
trauma is not just in the brain the
trauma stored emotionally in the body so
you want to take the body out of the
past out of the known what do you think
the body is going to say if it's been
conditioned to be the mind the unknown
is a scary place you step out into the
unknown you're going to be unprepared
for that trauma you don't know how it's
going to happen and so the person keeps
clinging to the known and but when the
person finally overcomes the emotion the
body literally is freed from the chains
of the past the side effect of that is
seeing the past from a greater level of
Consciousness lo and
behold there goes the Suicidal
Tendencies there goes the dysfunction
there goes the irritable bowel syndrome
that's was because the body was still
living in that past event by living by
the same emotion so the research on
memory is kind of fascinating and I just
I've studied it enough and and
and the way we recount the past is not
the way it happened even if you
absolutely think you remember it being
that way so we don't have the same brain
as we did when we were 8 years old or 12
years old or 20 years old we have a
different brain we have completely
different brain so the fabrication of
the story for many people they embellish
the story and make it seem even worse
than what it was but you're really what
you're saying is I changed in those
moments and from a biological standpoint
I haven't been able to change since so
let me tell you why it's been so hard
for me to change and the story becomes
dramatized or
embellished the person Works them up
fire themselves them into this emotional
froth and then fires and wires the same
circuits in the brain and they're
actually reaffirming their limitation
now there's nothing wrong with that I
think we're just taking too long right
so 50% of that story isn't even the
truth it means in a sense we're reliving
a miserable life that we never even had
and we don't want but but the but the
the unknown people would rather cling to
their
suffering this is not a judge judgement
we all do this we'd rather stay in the
known than take a chance in the unknown
because those emotions of survival are
saying what run from the unknown the
unknown is a scary place so now the
unknown you got to come up against that
moment where you're going to actually
leave that behind and step into the
unknown this is not a intellectual
process this is this is David and
Goliath there's a battle going on where
the body keeps wanting to go back to its
familiar State cuz it's subconsciously
been conditioned to be the Mind stay in
the
when you have a goal in your head it's
not even a goal it's a fantasy it's a
dream when you have a book like this you
can call it your goal book and you write
out your goals and you go through I'm
just about to take you through bit by
bit stage by stage you go back to that
but you can look at it you can touch it
you can just make it real so remember if
you do not write out your goals as a
plan and write out how to accomplish
them you don't have a goal you have a
wish you have a dream you have a
Daydream if you want to go get a pen get
a nice little book like this you can do
it on your phone too you can make a
document in your
computer and be prepared to make your
goals real so let's start now get your
book pause this if you need to go and
find one create one and I want you to
pick a goal and do not even start with I
want to lose £5 I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy goals no if
you can make your goals real you might
as well make them huge big enormous
phenomenal so if you say well I want
more money that's my oh hang on a minute
hey I got $10 here there you go you go
well that's not my goal but you said I
want more money and I learned this when
I used to work with women who were
infert that come in they go you know I
just want to be pregnant I want to be
pregnant so bad if I was is just
pregnant I go well as I look at your
notes you've been pregnant six times I
know I keep
miscarrying so being pregnant is not
your goal is it what isn't your goal to
carry to fullterm a healthy robust
bouncing baby to deliver a perfect baby
to be a great mom yeah that's my goal
why didn't you say that because you can
be pregnant lots of times and never have
a baby or you can say my goal is to have
a perfect baby how about this my goal is
to get lots of attention for what a
nervous twitch explosive gas that will
give you attention but that's not what
you want is it nobody wants explosive
gas so let's start with a big goal pause
if you need to take some time open your
book and write out a big goal now you
can have a career goal on whatever I'm
going to have my own company create my
own business invent something you can
have have a relationship goal my
relationship is wonderful we grow in
loving and respecting each other and you
can have a health goal but I want you to
pick one only one not three not five not
one goal it can be career can be Health
can be love pick one goal and then I
want you to decide why you want that
goal so much so the first thing is I
have a goal I want to have my own
business that's my goal and now you
going to go to the next page and write
out why do you want to have your own
business so much and the more reasoned
you can write out why the more
likely you will make that goal real so
write down why write down as many why as
as you can and
remember you can come back any time to
this and think Oh I thought of another
why and another why so leave plenty of
space take your time and when you've
done your wise go to another page and
write out who will benefit from you
achieving that goal of course you will
but who who will benefit for instance if
you have your own business you will
employ people who will benefit maybe
your kids will go to private school
maybe your business will allow you to
help your partner have their business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have to achieve that goal so write
out who will benefit from you achieving
goal who how and why will they benefit
you're going to buy your mama house put
your niece and nephew through private
school did you think of your mind is
like the genie in the bottle that says
your wish is my
command and I want you to understand
that every thought you think and every
word you say is a blueprint that your
mind body and S like you must make real
so when you write out your goals don't
say I wish I could be rich I long to be
in a loving relationship write it as if
it's already happening I am a
millionaire I am in a loving relation
you might go that doesn't make sense it
does make sense because your mind only
works in the present tense when you say
next year I'll have a bikini body it
doesn't know what next year is and so
you must write your goals in the present
tense I am I always I have I do this new
page is about your
discipline how many hours a day you
going to spend working on your goal how
often are you going to come back to this
book and look at it I want you to write
out I am I always I have I do and I want
you to fill that in you see the best
goal in the world will not work if you
don't work and many people fail at this
point they write out a goal my goal is
to be a millionaire my goal is to be
famous my goal is to be wildly in love
and they think that's it it's not it if
you want to be madly in love right at
all the reasons why but then you have
got to put yourself in front of the kind
of person you want to share your life
with if you want to start your own
business and you have a reason why you
also need to have the discipline to meet
people who will fund you sponsor you
joint venture with you so I want you to
really understand that the best goal
will not work if you don't work you can
have the start point but you have to
keep going many of the most successful
people ever say well you know I had a
goal Luther vras had a goal to be a
rockar and people said well you're an
overnight success he would I don't think
so you know I sang Jingles for KFC for
12 years that's a long night 12 years
and people said but Luther you're
singing on television that's cool you
get paid a lot of money for KFC he said
yeah but it's not my goal and he's stuck
it out and many people have got so close
to success and had to keep going and you
have to keep going
so look at your displine and decide you
will give more to your goal give even
more work on it look at it write it out
think about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal in
fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
I want to share three things with you
that I truly believe in this
manifestation thing now I'm not that
Voodoo um Law of Attraction guy but I
can tell you images uh pictures locking
in on something looking at uh looking at
other possibilities getting examples of
other people doing things is so so
valuable I mean it's our first way to
learn is to mimic is to see as babies
are are you know we see our
parents playing with their phones guess
what we want to pick up the phone and
play with the phone we see our parents
typing on a computer the kids want to do
what they want to come type on your
computer they don't even know how to use
it yet it's mimicking it's basically
taking something else somebody is done
boom Boat Boat I want boat okay it's the
way we learn to cook you watch your mom
cook eggs or fry bacon or make oatmeal
and she's got her own recipe guess what
that's the recipe you use so we end up
with all these little twerks and weird
habits uh back in the 50s you know all
all our parents smoked so what happened
when the kids grew up they picked up
smoking and alcohol Etc so the first
thing to do is on the manifestation
thing is you got to have some pictures
right if you you don't have those
pictures you know you don't you have
poverty around you you have struggle you
have like I grew up in struggle I didn't
grow up in poverty I grew up in a
struggle even though we had enough okay
it was always this idea that there
wasn't enough even when there was enough
it was crazy even when we had enough
dude it was always this idea that we
didn't have enough and I keep moving
around on this because I want you guys
to see these views they're just
ridiculous beautiful little town of
poano that is filled with magic
okay and for those of you who've never
traveled here or been over this part of
the world man come over here figure out
literally sit down this one of the
things I do first I take a lock in on a
picture bang yacht second thing I'm
going to do is try to get as close to
that thing on the manifestation thing
not the Law of Attraction but the law of
action okay first I see it then I'm
going to try to get I'm going to close
the distance now it took me 20 years to
get on this this Beast okay but what I
could do in between
then and I hope it doesn't take you 20
years is i' started collecting pictures
and images okay until I could actually
put my feet on get as close as you can
between you and the target so if it's a
boat a plane uh a business business
ownership an RV a car whatever it is
okay what you want to do is take
pictures of it collect images of it okay
maybe reinforce those by looking at them
often thinking about them just playing
with it don't even worry about how to
get it uh what it's going to take to get
it and the second thing is to start like
closing the distance between you and
that image could be pictures could be
images could be research it could be you
going to the car dealership and actually
sitting in the car you know getting an
appointment to go see the house I
remember this is insane to think this
but I remember when I did not
think that I could get somebody to show
me a house I remember when I was like I
was lan and I were in La late I wanted
to see this house that was for sale and
I was concerned that they wouldn't think
enough of me to even let me see the
house so if you guys have ever struggled
with all this limited thinking okay but
later I bought the house I was Lally
bought the house ended up making on that
house I made like $12 million or
something and I did not think when I
went into the house that I was going to
be able to even see the house so if you
suffer from a self-esteem issue
um
or sense of self or was telling my
daughter the other day I said man I've
had self-esteem issues my whole life not
thinking I was good enough not thinking
I can get there I'm still doing it
today you know I started thinking about
you know last time I was here 20 years
ago one day I'm going be on a boat here
in poano now I'm thinking one day I'm
going to be here on my own boat what do
you want to be on okay so number one
okay take a picture of it two close the
distance and three at some point you're
going to have to start doing the math
and the math for me is this what would
it take to buy this what is the
resources the beans the coins the
dollars the energy the output the number
of people I need to make contact with
and if I can't figure that out just
figure this simple math out how
did uh he do it how
did he do it how did he do it what
business are they
what did they do to do this how did they
get it and maybe it's just a charter
okay so nothing wrong with that okay
hope you guys do well hope you figure
out some things that really get rich in
your mind about your manifestations
about what you want what your purpose is
what's driving you to fuel you so you
can and your you and your family can
have a great life if you ever get to
post
aano okay let me know the reason so many
people aren't productive throughout the
day is not only because they don't have
their purpose and their psychology and
their physiology supporting them but
also because they're going through the
day in an ignorant way you know they're
going through the day Focus solely on
responding to everybody else's
emergencies you know here's what most
people do they wake up they get ready
for the day they go through the they go
to work they're not really thinking
about anything yet they're just kind of
going through the motions they get to
work and what do they do they open up
their email inbox which is the worst
thing you could ever do to be productive
your inbox is a nice organizing system
of other people's agendas that's what an
inbox really is it's a nice organizing
system other every email in there is
someone needing something from you or
pulling from you that's what most of
them are isn't it true and so what most
people do is they open up their inbox
and they start responding to other
people's emergencies or they start they
start looking through all their emails
to see well what am I supposed to do
today or what's the biggest fire I have
to fight today in other words they're
living their life in
reaction versus living their life in
intention in intelligence in Direction
they're not focused on what to do
throughout the day they're just saying
well I'll do this because that's what
popped up today you know so for
personally I never even check email
until 10:00 a.m. when I get up and I'm
looking at everything I'm sit down and I
strategize my day before I ever even
think about checking my email and then I
might only check my email once or twice
a day because I set up all other systems
to support my ability to be productive
because in your life I'm guessing that
you're only really making money if
you're producing and in my my industry I
live in the experts industry that's the
sort of the self-help spirituality
business growth world where we offer
advice to other people about how they
can improve their life or build their
business that's the expert industry in
the expert industry most people are
really struggling to be productive
because we're creatives right we have so
many great ideas and so many great
intentions throughout the day and we
have so many ideas we can never actually
accomplish them maybe you're the same
maybe at base you're really a Creator
and you have all these ideas of so many
things you want to do but you've never
really been able to organize them and
get them done because you haven't set up
systems to support your levels of
productivity let's start with at the
beginning of your day uh I'm going to
just jump into one little thing that I
do at the beginning of the day it's not
the very beginning but I think it will
help you and it's a way of organizing my
day and I call this onepage productivity
it's just a simple sheet of paper that I
have that I fill in when the morning
after I've gone out and I've exercised
that's a piece of my morning activity is
mastering my physiology so I can become
a high performer starts with me drinking
lots of water in the morning eating the
right things going for a little quick
run or workout or even just a brisk walk
to energize my body and my mind so that
I can be creative and think and when I
get back to my office and it's time to
actually work I do this onepage
productivity sheet and this onepage
productivity sheet helps me really think
through what I need to do throughout the
day so here's the three elements of this
and by the way below this video you can
download this sheet and you can use it
on your daily life let me walk you
through how to use it basically there's
three elements of the onepage
productivity the first element is Major
projects these major projects usually if
you any given person probably has oh I
don't know you know like three big
buckets of pro projects that they're
working on so I might be working on you
know writing a new book I might be
working on doing a new seminar I might
be working on you know reinvigorating my
online marketing those are big big these
are big bucket projects that aren't
necessarily they're not the priorities
for the day these are the big Vision
these connect me to the what are the big
things I'm doing and any given person if
they're well organized they're probably
only working on three maybe five main
projects so what I want you to do when
you start out in the morning to keep you
big thinking big and thinking outside of
just the day to focus is you know and in
the high performance Academy we've
already talked about purpose so we're
already engaged there okay this is just
a little snippet I want you to think
about the big picture of your projects
and I want you to think about what are
the five
things that you would have to do to move
these projects forward this is not five
things that you need to move them
forward today that's your priorities
your projects are just in general what
are the big things that you need to do
the big five things that you would have
to do so for example if online marketing
is one of my big projects in reinv one
of the things I might have to do is
learn to code a web page right or learn
to design a web page now that's a
project it doesn't mean that today I'm
going to learn how to do it it just
means in general that's one of the
things I will have to do so these are
what are the five big things you would
have to do to actually make that project
come into fruition what would you have
to learn what would you have to go out
and master what would you have to Who
Would you you have to contact what are
the things you would have to do for your
big projects
next is people category in this people
category I want you to think of two
things in the people category the people
category is really important for high
performers because High performers
really get ahead not just because of who
they know but how they're engaging who
they know right what they're asking for
what they're doing so the people
category that I want you to think of
each morning on this onepage
productivity is two categories one I
want you to sit down and think of who do
you need to reach out to
today who do you need to reach out to so
if I want to learn coding as an example
in general I might want to schedule some
time with a coder or web designer so I'm
like I'm going to have to reach out to a
coder or web designer today and this is
important because most people when they
open up their inbox they just start
replying to all these things when I open
my inbox the first thing I do is I send
out these emails people I need to reach
out to it's the first thing that I do
when I open my inbox as an example very
first thing is send out all the emails
of people I need to reach out to the
second category
here is the people that you are waiting
on right given any person's real
schedule you're waiting on somebody to
give you some information or a decision
to move forward in your day isn't it
true you're waiting on something from
somebody so that you can move forward
and most people they just sit there and
they wait for the email to pop up they
they hope that it's going to come they
don't do anything about it the second
thing I do when I open my inbox after I
reach out to the people I reach out to
the people who I'm waiting on and I say
something specific to them so let me
give you an example of how this actually
might operationalize in the day when I
open my inbox I'll look in my emails for
these people first and foremost it's the
first thing I'll do after I send out the
ones I need to reach out to
strategically I'll say who am I waiting
on I'll look at and I'll open up their
inbox or open up their email to to see
if I got what I needed if I didn't I
send an email right back to them to make
sure I get what I need as fast as
possible so yes there's an element of
you hounding people to become productive
you know most people are just sitting
around waiting for other people to help
their dreams come true for me I'm
chasing people down right you know I
want to for high performers there's a
level of impatience there you know if
you want to become a high performer you
got to have this level of impatience
that says I need to accomplish this I
need to do this let's go let's go let's
go you need to be on a faster path in
life not stressed out more but more
focused on achieving what you need to do
to become happy to become successful not
just because someday that's going to
happen for you but in the moment in the
moment being happy and successful so
that you can be happy and successful I
hope that makes sense ultimately that's
the people category then the next
category is the priority category okay
your priority category is what are the
10 things that you've got to accomplish
today these are the 10 must do items
this is sort of like your to-do list but
it's ranked in the order of most
importance it's very simple right
because to-do lists are great I'm all
for them all I'm all four day planners
because it helps you achieve some of
these things but at the end of the day
you got to think about okay what are my
real priorities today and here's what
I'll often do depending on how big these
are and how important they are when I
get to my when I WR all these out here's
how my day works here's the order of
things that I'll achieve throughout the
day first I'll do whatever it takes to
achieve these priorities whether it is
sending an email or whether it is you
know running an errand or whether it's
calling somebody these priorities in my
day happen first often before I even
open my inbox or if I have to open my
inbox I'll wait but priorities first
accomplish these first no matter what
these get done first before I respond to
any anybody else's emergency or go
through all my inbox these
first then I move up second I'll go okay
who am I waiting on and who do I need to
reach out to the people category I'll do
that now often this will take most of
the entire day and then I'll say if
there's any given time left in the day
I'll Focus back on the bigger projects
thinking about what it's going to take
to accomplish them let's just say that
lack is ingrained in there you got the
story you lived on the streets you lost
everything you got betrayed your
business partner took everything took
your wife took you got the story in the
half okay okay you got to start telling
a new story of the future right you got
to believe in that future more than you
have to believe in the past so how do
you do that you only believe in the past
when you feel the emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
of the future right okay so in order for
us to change a belief or perception
about oursel and our
lives we have to make make a decision
with such firm
intention that the amplitude of that
decision carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardware
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we
downregulate that old belief if the
trauma created emotional quoti of six or
seven then your decision to change your
belief's got to be a nine right and you
got to come out of your resting state
and that moment has to Define you you
could say I know exactly where I was the
time and day it was who I was with when
I made my mind up to change right cuz
you created a long-term memory long-term
memories are creat
[Music]
but the amplitude of that emotion is
greater than the Betrayal Boom the body
starts responding to the mind you're
actually giving your body a taste of the
future emotionally so you brand your
impossible no your body is actually
getting the taste of that future event
it's experiencing the future now exact
big explosion on the quantum field big
explosion so the side effect of that is
if you combine that clear intention with
that elevated emotion you're basically
remembering your future and it looks no
different than remembering your past
think neurologically within the circuits
of that memory and feel within the
emotions of that new belief and watch
your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lack we in lack or separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for
us to become abundant we have to
overcome the old personality and that's
95% of who we are right yes so then the
side effect of the beginning of this
process is a lot of discomfort it is a
lot of discomfort because you're
stepping outside the known into the
unknown and now you can't predict scary
no no you you'd rather hold on to your
lack the pain
rather tell the story of that at least
it makes you feel something that's
familiar when you step outside and
you're saying I'm not going to complain
about money any longer I'm not going to
complain about I don't have any I'm not
going to judge other people who do I'm
not going to say I can I'm not worthy
it's never going to work all those
things got to go I'm not going to feel
lack I'm not going to feel unworthy I'm
not going to feel separation I'm not
going to feel resentment these are the
things that are keeping my reality the
same now it's no longer about abundance
about who you become mhm so the
overcoming process becomes The Becoming
process and so many people come through
this work they want abundance they want
healing they want a new relationship
they want a new career they want the
mystical but really they want wholeness
and and they want healing they want
peace they want wholeness because they
feel unho well well when you're in lack
or you're in separation you're not whole
imagine feeling so much wholeness that's
impossible to want that's what our
that's what we're working on with people
then you can really enjoy a sunset then
you can really really enjoy a meal then
you can really enjoy your friends then
you can I I I I talk to people that are
very abundant I mean in the billions
abundant and you know so many of them
say we're in misery whole we're in agony
because they can't enjoy life anymore
that's what they want I mean people want
abundance to be able to enjoy life they
want to be able to do whatever they want
with whoever they want as many times as
they want wherever they want that's
Freedom right we want abundance is the
sponsoring thought is really they want
freedom right or whatever their
sponsoring thought would be
right because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for The Ultimate Guide to Personal
Mastery and manifestation check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there maybe a time period
when you don't know exactly what to do
with your so-called life which is not
yours so you just being as still as
possible do your whatever activity
you're already doing and but bring
Stillness